all right hutch yes touch uh where'd you
grow up where are you from originally uh
venice beach california yes los angeles
here um
tell me about your parents you had mom
and dad yeah i have a father my my
mother um split when i was young when i
was six
so i was raised by my dad single dad
good man how would you describe your
childhood
um
uh
i i would say less than desirable
my my mom split
when i was
six so she split from my dad for his
brother
so there was there was dad and then
there was uncle jerry dad
and um
he was a terror topanga he lived in a
place called the pancake canyon he was
known for being nuts up there so we had
the mandatory visits was not
it was mandatory let's say that you know
had to
you made through high school
i did i did i graduated high school um
in 2002 i think
i aged myself
um
but what did you do after school
oh well in school i started getting in
trouble i started in good trouble in to
my teen years i was in angry i was
overweight i grew too fast and um
i
didn't have a lot of money we didn't
have a lot of money so
los angeles is very um let's say they're
superficial you know what you what
you're wearing what you look like the
things you have on you
is what you are
is how it was perceived
and um we didn't have much of anything
so i wasn't really treated
you know in the cool kid classes and
stuff
so i had to act out
acting out was a good way of getting
people to either look at me the way i
want them to or not look at me at all so
and then after school
after school i joined the army i was
getting into trouble i was in a lot of
trouble
and this is right after 9 11. so 9 11
happened and then i was a senior in high
school
so i joined right out of high school
basically
i had a buddy that was going in
my buddy ryan and um
he
said hey dude i'm doing it you know you
got to get out of here
you know so why don't you
why don't we do it together so we did we
joined the buddy program and then i
wound up in
fort bragg north carolina in the 82nd
airborne division
and deployed to afghanistan in 2005.
and that was
my first introduction to adulthood
was deploying to a third world country
so you went to afghanistan went to
afghanistan 2005. um tell me about that
i learned some things i
we were we were artillery
in afghanistan so we did
um we we were in this place called the
kaust bowl
and
it was right on the border of pakistan
really near the border pakistan
northeastern
part of afghanistan northeast province
and um
we we basically
held this border
with our artillery pieces
by blowing people up you know and
that was what
we were being introduced to as well was
they were blowing us up and we were
returning fire and stuff like that
not minutes small arms fire at all not
much
um face-to-face interaction with with
the enemy it was
more they'd shoot rockets or mortars or
some sf base would need support and we
would support them and
yeah
that's
yeah nobody got hurt in my unit
during that deployment thankfully
that was uh it was one of the better
ones i guess the better deployments of
my two deployments
that one
sha it more created bonds between us we
got really close tight-knit things of
that nature and then
we came back with this like a good
feeling
like we accomplished something like
there was something that
needed to be done we were sent there to
do it and then we came back and it was
done you know and um
the day we got back to fort bragg
my dad i remember my dad was there but i
remember they gave us our deployment
orders to iraq that day
the day we got back yeah you got back
good news you're leaving again yeah in
365 days you will be returning
to iraq and that was in 2006 is when we
got to no yeah
2007.
so i went to afghanistan 2005 2006 spent
365 days back on day 366 i was on my way
to iraq
so then so then we spend we spent a year
back
and um
it was a good year we were full of like
excitement and youth and um
this feeling of accomplishment and love
we had this bond of camaraderie that was
real it was real
and i missed that more than anything but
and then we we deployed iraq
and the whole thing flipped upside down
on our heads
that's when it changed
we went from artillery
to
there wasn't such a need for artillery
because it's an indirect fire right
there's a lot of collateral damage
especially in an urban environment
in an urban city you start shooting
artillery rounds big artillery rounds
and things go bad so they switched our
unit into convoy escort teams set teams
is what they call them
um
and um these teams what we did was there
was about five gun trucks
humvees armored
with heavy you know heavy um
heavy
you know
guns we're big we used large weapons on
them and um
they
we would take five gun trucks and escort
like 30 or 40 18 wheelers
over like a kilometer long strip so it
was a the convoys were like over half a
mile
from the first truck to the last truck
and five trucks to guard 30
um you know big wheelers on what was
called the main supply route tampa and
it went from kuwait to turkey
and it cut straight through the center
of the country goes through baghdad and
kind of skirts the west side of baghdad
and then comes out and around and keeps
heading north to cook all of it and it
goes up to turkey um
and uh that's that was like
the worst place you could be in 2007 in
2008. we were at the end of the surge so
general petraeus had called up the surge
this he wanted all these boots on the
ground he wanted all these soldiers
to hold down the city i mean to hold
down the country in order to
rectify
what needed to be done i guess and so he
called for the surge is what it was
called and there was i think he was like
i don't know i couldn't tell you tens of
thousands of troops that were called on
top additionally on top of what was
already in country and um
we were at the tail end of that
and um
yeah convoys convoys combos convoys and
the worst place you could be at that
time because they started
they started we started picking up on
the way that they were you know they
were they stopped engaging so front
um
front line like
um
what's the word
not not so um they wouldn't engage so
face to face as much as it was all
ieds
improvised explosive devices blown us up
and then
i um ieds and efps these like um
[Music]
they were taking these like it would
look like a coffee can they take a
cylinder like a cylindrical um
a cylinder and then they would take
nickel and copper or just copper
and concave it and put on the end and
then put some sort of plastic explosive
in there right
and then they would they would chip out
a curb
and set it in there
and then put like the the insulation
foam and put it with dirt and then you
couldn't even you wouldn't even know it
was there and then when they blow this
thing it burns at like 9000 degrees
and it's moving through steel like it's
not there and it's like a softball of
molten copper
moving extremely fast and
they just
it made our armor like not like it
wasn't there literally and people were
getting [ __ ] up [ __ ] up
tearing people in in in
pieces there was literally splitting
people in half
um
it was taking like
it would take like four like
it could take
a a fully armored truck with with four
well
um
like well
put together men
and liquidate them
in the second
in the second
it could take everything they had and
lay it to waste without and this is
costing them nothing you know it's
costing them 10 bucks and
the way we were told is it was like it
was in a i don't know i don't know
where they got the technology but i'm
sure it came from us at some point you
know it came from us through iran and
then from iran
and it came bit us back in the ass and
um
witnessing
human beings
display carnage upon each other
in your early twenties
is not natural
no matter how much
we see war as a natural state of being
no matter how much we think it is normal
to be at war
there's nothing natural about it
the way that people hum
a young man can turn into a monster
and then
go right back to being a young man is
it's breathtaking
looking back at what we were capable of
doing
or what
i saw friends be
capable of doing
and
and then going back and
returning to their families
you know
picking up their kid coming off the
plane and picking up their little girl
and spinning around and kissing him on
the face and sitting back down and
thinking i saw you do some [ __ ] that
would [ __ ]
make that little girl's throat for the
rest of her life
you know
but then
and then you hear this you hear a very
interesting cliche
you had to
you did what you had to do and it's like
you're right
you're right you got us there we did
what we had to do
but
how much of it was absolutely necessary
you know the only way i've been able to
to
um come to terms with
the things that have that i witnessed
there and the things that i participated
in
was like this if i see
america's military as a
as a system
and it plays a part in a larger system
of the of a world peace right
so the military might of the united
states having the ability to take
hundreds of thousands of men place them
in a foreign country quickly
overthrow the government
and do it by force with guns and willing
to apply death to as many people as
needed to do so
kept the world in somewhat
at peace
our ability to show that might
i believe has kept the world relatively
at peace right now i wouldn't say so
with the current state of affairs in in
um
in ukraine but
[Music]
the the idea that somebody can do that
that a country a nation is capable of
doing that
i'd like to say that my participation in
that
is a form of security and freedom for
some
that's the only way i've been able to
justify or chalk up what i
participated in
as
okay
as something that was necessary
because do i believe that
anybody's individual freedoms at home
were safer
due to my
due to the things that i did over there
um
like like um
on its face no
on its face no but as a part of that
system yes
you know i don't believe that that
anybody was safer
because
my ability to take another human life
at call at will
on call
um
[Music]
kept
i guess that's the system that that
that works that's the system that kept
everybody safer but my my actual doing
it
participating in it
knowing it to be what was right at the
time
no
no
i don't believe anybody's freedoms were
individually safer because
i took him in life at that time
and now to come home at 24
and try to justify all that and and
put it in a picture that is pretty
is impossible it wasn't possible
and
i got hurt so because i got hurt i was
given drugs
and
taking those drugs made things much
easier
to cope with if i can take a substance
and immediately
control an emotion
this emotion bothers me it makes me
uncomfortable i can take this substance
and it will [ __ ] curb that for a
moment
that is my new natural state of being
was where i went
that was my new natural state of being
and
um
i was also
involved in a crime
committed
in iraq i wasn't there
i mean it's all public record now but
like i wasn't there
when it happened there was money stolen
u.s currency bulk u.s currency stolen
from the department of finance at the
dod
in iraq and money was mailed to me and
other people
and i got in trouble for that you know i
ended up getting arrested for it and
everything like that and did you know
was right down here on alameda
at the mdc there metropolitan necessary
and did some did
did my federal time for that
you know paid back my debt that way what
was the hardest thing you personally had
to experience while you were there
in iraq yeah i mean like
coping um
somebody that you love care for being
there and then the next day they're not
that was my first experience of real
death
my first experience of death was
introduced me in that manner i you know
nobody in my family really died when i
was a kid
i had no real tragic you know i had a
couple friends in high school that like
you know car accident
um
suicide drug overdose
uh gang violence
there's plenty of gang violence in my
high school plenty of big violence
venice high in the late 90s was was
yeah it was a trip it was a trip and
we're in white what being
caucasian
was a minority in the school
so anywhere you're a minority you're
going to feel it
you're going to know it you know you're
gonna you're gonna feel that that thing
of that but back to iraq that was my
only introduction to death was was that
manner was people
was
small things that you think of as
natural causes almost you know people
kids die young you know things happen
when you're in school and uh when you're
a kid
accidents and things like that but then
going to iraq and having somebody that
you know is your friend your family your
loved one
and your brothers are your friends your
family your loved ones there
they are the people that you care about
the most and they are the most important
thing in the world to you
um
disappear
no trace like that was it you know when
an ied goes off and a truck goes up and
it's a mushroom cloud and the doors go
flying there's no remnants of your
friend
friends
there's no
nothing to send home you know that's it
it's a bit it's vapor
and dealing with that was not easy
coming back you know i'd be on base and
and another set team would be out and
we'd get the news you know so a radio
come in and somebody run and bang on it
hey you hear what happened no what
happened what's his name watch the leg
it's like lost a [ __ ] leg
he's 22 years old what do you mean lost
a leg
you know and these are realities
that everybody thinks of it's like oh
well that's what you were doing it's
like oh you go try it you you tell me
that's natural
the feeling you get in your heart when
you know that you could be the next
person to lose a [ __ ] leg or your
life
it's not easy it's not easy
and that's the part that i think people
fail to grasp is that
yes
we're expected to do it yes i
volunteered i know this
um
but in the end
when it's all said and done
how much of it
you know when people do crimes okay for
example when somebody commits a crime
and they go to jail you lay up at night
and you think [ __ ] i did this crime i'm
in jail for it this [ __ ] sucks
you know
but when you go to war
and you come back
it's not as easy to justify like that
it's not so cut and dry
it's not so black and white like oh i
went to war that's why i snatched that
life up
that's why i went over there and did
what i did
and
it's easy to say it i guess and it's
it's easier to write it down on paper
but it's not easy to feel it
there are so many feelings that come
along with this [ __ ]
um
[Music]
when you get when you um when you when
you breach a a house or breach a a
a building or somewhere that needs to be
breached
um
whoever
you know tears the hinges down kicks the
door turns around immediately usually or
that's what that was the tactic then
um so i was a number four man a door guy
for one of these hits for one of these
things and it was a courtyard and we hit
the courtyard door and move into the
building to the house and
you can hear the rustling of people so
you're blowing the hinges off the door
right so you i'm hearing on the other
side of the door like we're listening to
see what's going like and you can hear
mumbling and people rustling around a
bit
so i go to blow the hinges i hit the top
hinge hit the bottom hinge with the
mossberg 500 shotgun and i go for the
center hinge and i pause for a second
let's [ __ ] it boom and i hit the center
hinge kicked the door in in my mind i
thought i could kick the storm without
blowing that hinge i don't know why
but that flash that flashed to me at
that point was you know you might not
have to hit this hinge
i kick the door down door comes down and
before i can turn around i see what was
on the other side of that hint that
center hinge
and it was somebody that was the size of
a center hinge
so you can do the math on that a center
hand leaves somewhere around three four
feet on a door
so there was something on the inside of
that hinge and the kid was hiding so
that when the door went open it would
swing open he'd be behind it
and not want to see him you know
and
[Music]
i live with that
and that's an emotion that you have to
put down
in your early 20s
today
every day of your life today yeah and i
have a nine-year-old son
and he's about that height
and the crazy part
is that imagine
the kid growing up with you
in your dreams and your nightmares
with half a [ __ ] head
and no face
but as you grow older so do they
imagine that
so
i've had nightmares
recently this year
to where the [ __ ] kid is an adult
with the same face and head missing
walking around in the background of the
dream
that will wake you up with some anxiety
that'll put a needle in your arm
that'll put you on some [ __ ] drugs
now it seems like a cartoon
you know just to say it out loud you
know
that's a reality for me
now tell me that
you had to do what you had to do
you know
tell me those words bring me comfort
would bring anybody comfort
in that situation
there is no comfort
for that that is human carnage
that is the worst of humanity
and for have somebody pat me on the back
and put a ribbon on my chest and so you
did a good job this year
we'll eat you alive it eats your soul
i felt like i used to have my military
id and people used to like looking at it
because you could see
the difference in what i was as a human
being when i first got back and they
took a picture of the id
i look so much different than i do now
there's so much life in me now
because i've done so much work on it you
know
but it has taken
as much time working on
my
mind to be a functioning disabled vet in
my manner
and to be so high functioning has taken
extensive work
a lot of awareness therapy
oh yeah
therapy beyond yeah therapy
being open-minded to therapy to to
taking my meds i take medication um i
take no um
[Music]
no immediate cause no immediate i take
no immediate effect medications so you
can't take it and get a feeling you know
if they're all you know you have to take
them for two or three weeks before they
start to take effect and they've been
very helpful for me to slow down and
to catch things before my emotions take
over my entire body and mind and
run along with that the way they do um
anger
was the beginning
and because of that i my brother made me
stop drinking
he said i will never my brother and i
are very close and he said i'll never be
around you
if you drink so i stopped drinking
because i would black out and
say things things were coming out of my
mouth
like what i just told you and people
would start crying
and i'm looking at him and spitting at
him and
they're like what's wrong with you man
you know what's wrong with you
and
and they felt bad for me you know a lot
of people felt bad
and i [ __ ] i scoffed at their pity
and
you don't understand is a cliche phrase
in this you know
um you don't understand is it is a
cliche phrase that we like to say
it's okay as a phrase that other people
like to say
you had to do it is another thing people
like to say these phrases should all be
very you know we should be very very
careful with these things
every individual veteran every veteran
that is affected by war
is individually affected
and has their individual
their emotions are triggered
differently than other people with a
similar story or somebody could have
been the same
you know
breach team as me that don't feel the
same that i do
you know didn't don't have the same
regrets or threw up as they were coming
in the room
you know
um
i remember shaking
and
uncontrollably shaking
and thinking this is
powerful
whatever's happening to me is powerful
you know
there are certain drugs i've done that
i've said wow this is a powerful
substance
and there are things that can affect our
emotions that
i don't think can be described by a
doctor or you know or by
i don't think it could be cured by
medication
i think it's all an individual journey
you know to get to the bottom of
what i've done
what's been done to me
how do i perceive these things
how do i apply that perception
to my
current state of being
um
i would hope anybody
anybody that's been through that
would seek help
because otherwise you're going to hurt
yourself or somebody else
you know because our emotions become so
powerful we cannot control ourselves
and this is a part of humanity you know
this is what a part of what makes us
human when we love we love big
and when we hurt we hurt big
and
these big emotions are dangerous they
can be very very dangerous
i believe
um
i've learned how to deal with these
things
my son was born
when my son was born in 2013
and i don't this doesn't happen for
everyone but i am one of these cliche
cases that it changed my life
my baby
he gave me a reason to live
and he wasn't he was not an accident
but he was accidental
he happened accidentally but he's not an
accident um
my son was born he was conceived in
rehab
i
was she winked i smiled there was day
room two was open saturday night and my
son was born
um
she's not been a part of his life at all
she's a meth addict and has been gone
his entire life he's never met her
he's asked me questions recently about
her and um i don't talk down on her and
there's no need
she wasn't there
and when you're a parent that isn't
there or not present the other parent
doesn't have to talk down on you the kid
will know
when they grow up they know they'll
remember every bit of time you weren't
there
so you're raising your son by myself
and i have
and i mean i have a good family my
father is a great man and he's helped me
when he can and when i needed my
brothers and sisters that have you know
showed up for me
when it comes to that to being a father
and i've had a good experience as a
father my son is happy to be my son and
i'm happy to be his dad you know and
that is the only thing i can say that
has taken me out of that has get put
humanity back into me has started to
rebuild my soul
and my son my son will wake me up at
night because we still sleep in the same
bed sometimes and he'll wake me up and
and dad dad you're okay dad you're okay
and i know i was having a nightmare
you know because my son's shaking me and
telling me it's okay dad you're okay
my baby my baby has had to wake me up
and say you're okay dad
you know
he's nine he turns nine in july so he
kind of understands what he does and my
son is extremely empathetic and he's
such a good boy
he's he doesn't he didn't have the same
problems i did when i was young
you know i was my father was
emotionally inept
and i don't blame him my dad's a vietnam
vet
his dad was a world war ii vet
you know but my father just cannot
express emotions verbally
you know and luckily i learned to do
that because
i didn't want my son to have the same
experience as i did
i didn't want my son my father was a bit
hard with his hand
you know i'm not gonna say my dad was an
abusive son of a [ __ ] but he was tough
you know he was tough
and he did it by himself he raised us
alone you know my mom split so
i had that going for me was i was raised
by a good single father you know
and my dad never drank in front of us he
never smoked cigarettes never smoked
drugs nothing in front of us
um my son's never seen me drunk
he see me on drugs but i don't think he
knew it you know i've never i don't
change
what foot drug did you play around with
i've messed around with them all but uh
primarily was was heroin and you're
clean now yeah probably how long have
you been clean um
uh this run has been
three and a half years so before that it
was um
it was five
but
yeah i've been cleaning most
ninety percent of my son's life
luckily
and when i wasn't i asked
somebody that was clean to take care of
him because i didn't want him to see me
like that you know
and he understands now and i mean i've
had little relapses and stuff you know
stuff in between when i say three and a
half years i don't i don't i'm not
counting it like like um
every you know every single day you've
been clean you know if i got high in
between here on this weekend i got high
that weekend but i've gone to no
destroying my life runs or use drugs to
where to to
to a part of where my life has been in
detriment you know due to it
luckily you know and i i sought help
and because i saw help i have financial
assistance from the va i get a um
i get a um
you know the va gives me a compensation
every month
for the
the amount of my life that has changed
due to the war
so
that's a good thing that helps us a lot
you know that always pays the rent
it's hard to hold a job for more than a
year i don't know why i'm a good
employee but since since
yeah
since the war it's i guess they
attribute it to the ptsd i guess it's a
common thing for guys with my diagnosis
i have severe post traumatic stress
disorder from prolonged combat exposure
is was is the diagnosis
and
what that turns into is that i guess
i don't get bored but i don't find the
same meaning
in the stuff i do
you know
i guess i i can't find a deep meaning in
anything that i do
that keeps me occupied from where they
are so i'll start working i'll get
really good at it
and then i'll i'll split as soon as i
feel like i've mastered it i'm out you
know and that's disappointing because
there's been some people have put some
really good opportunities in front of me
and i've you know
i've i haven't i don't think i've [ __ ]
on them as much as
i just wasn't able to give them what
they deserved was they took all this
time and trained me to do something and
then i never really
they never really got the payoff but
imagine after seeing the things you saw
and experiencing what you experienced
to do a job that doesn't have a
tremendous amount of meaning
just ends up feeling really empty
quickly yeah i i think that
you know i never really looked at it
like that i never put it that way
meaningful
that's i guess that's from today i said
that
i'm glad i did i'm
i haven't been able to find it i had
meaning
i felt like there was a lot of meaning
in what i was doing there whether it was
right or wrong there was a there was
meaning and there was a cause that i hid
behind
it's it's hard to
seek
deep meaning after things in your life
is where on a day-to-day basis
everything is like life or death as they
say
it's not that simple but it is
you can paint it that way um
how do you find meaning in
hanging drywall
or or serving a person food you know and
i'm not saying that there isn't what i'm
saying is the the journey to find that
meaning becomes very harrowing
you know it takes a lot to find meaning
in something that's seemingly so trivial
after that after you experience
something of that manner you know um
i
i've tried
i've tried i did i've done i did
hardwood floors for a long time
electrical work i did um tattooing i've
done a lot of things that i like doing
but i don't i i'm gonna end up having to
work with people
if i don't work with people i won't
succeed i don't think because i find
like
the meaning that i found in my journey
is that being able to relate with
somebody or say somebody hey man
i do get it
is is better than anything else you know
i did i did work in treatment for a long
time i worked in treatment that's
that that was um
that was very
fulfilling
working in treatment ended up working
for the scumbag who like is in prison
for life now so you know in the end it
didn't feel so good but in the in the
moment helping people
really felt meaningful
and that's the only thing that i think
you know if you're if you're if there's
a veteran struggling find another
veteran that's struggling
and i guarantee you guys you guys will
work something out you know
i've there's a lot of cool
community-based veterans veteran
programs and stuff like that to help
each other but
that one-on-one that being able to stand
next to each other and say we don't have
to say it we get it
you know
i understand
problems that people are having in these
in these small tasks if they're veterans
sometimes i i understand it better than
they do or vis-a-vis you know they they
understand my problems better than i do
um
it's one that's one thing is that that
that camaraderie never dies
the camaraderie never dies and when you
find another veteran or somebody that's
experienced what you've experienced
explore their
perception
how did they see their problem how did
it affect them emotionally how did they
how are they dealing with the how have
they dealt with it
helping people has been the only thing
that i've felt i've found that that
brings meaning to my life
that makes perfect sense
and it's it's a
i know i don't know how to pursue it you
know i don't know which route to go
or that but at least i know it at least
you're probably still healing even after
all these years yeah
at least my son would tell you i am wait
what's your view on war
gosh
you have airborne tattooed on your
forehead so yeah i do um my view on war
is this is that
it has it is for the last couple
thousand years been a natural state of
being for humanity
i don't think it's natural
you know um
it has been a badge i've been able to
wear proudly
and that i've been able to use to keep
people at bay people away from me that
that may be dangerous or you know maybe
i've used it as a um
[Music]
as a mask
we all wear masks and my veteran mask is
a is a good one
it it
gives people a pre
it kind of puts people at a certain way
of saying okay this person is
i can assume this make some assumptions
that i may be a little more dangerous
than the average person i may
understand death better than the average
person i may have dealt death i may have
all these things made so you have to
kind of you know
figure me out before you can step all
over me which has been very helpful and
but
my view on war is that
it's the most necessary unnecessary
thing we we do
it's the most unnecessary necessary
thing we do
whichever way you want to spin it it
seems that we can't get away from it
but it's wrong
there's no
time
that taking another human being's life
is natural or okay
[Music]
even if you say oh well i did it to save
this person it's like well that person
shouldn't have been doing it
you know if you had to kill someone
because they were going to kill you
doesn't mean it's natural that they were
trying what they were trying to do was
naturally wasn't right
you know
so there's no time
that taking another human being's life
is natural
or right
i think if we all could get that through
our [ __ ] heads
we'd be a lot better off you know if
that wasn't a solution
you know war is a solution to what
people
want
if you if if i want something and i'm
not getting it
i take enough life
to where people say i don't want you to
take mine so here
that is not an insane concept to
everyone
how is that not in pure insanity
where it's i
and you how do you stop it
with war
right he you know
when somebody has a stick you got to get
a bigger stick i
where does the cycle like where do we
get a break in this closed loop
you know because we've already committed
so much atrocity and war and so much war
there's no break in the loop it's a
closed loop cycle now it's it's running
itself
it's like oh it's a natural state it's
like oh what happened oh this person
isn't doing what we want them to oh why
not it doesn't matter kill him
it's like [ __ ] man
you know oh these people are coming
across this invisible line we have
painted as our border and we say that
this is ours and that's yours and you
don't come over here without our
permission and if we don't give you
permission you stay you stay
and if you don't like it we'll kill you
[ __ ] man
how is that the end-all
how is it
you know how has that become our
our end-all you don't like my gangster i
don't like your gangster bang you're
dead and that's the end all
i don't think religion is doing a very
good job
but
god we gotta have a better way
there's gotta be there's gotta be i know
it's just you and me talking i'm sorry
but
there's gotta be something more than
that you think after all these years
we'd figure some other way human
discourse man you know
tradition has been the death of human
discourse
i don't
you know i
i don't want my son
to live in a world of war
he knows i've been able to tell he knows
what's going on right now and ukraine is
wrong
he knows it's wrong whether our
participation and utilizing it as a
proxy country is is wrong or not it's
all wrong
no one should have to die
over somebody else's opinion or belief
you know
and i think a lot of what we do now is
we kill in belief out of our beliefs we
i can't imagine
man can't imagine to do that again
as an adult as a good person i'm a good
person
i'm not a bad person
having to do that again
there's no purpose you know there's
nothing
[Music]
there's a hell of a world we live in
the smarter we get the more dangerous we
become yeah
all right hutch
thank you so much for sharing your story
thank you fascinating thank you thank
you
you